So this is a program
that is motivated and
driven
by a really long-term vision
to understand
the fundamental building blocks
of matter
and how we behave.
This is one of these driving questions of humanity
that we want to understand how our world works,
that we want to understand where we are coming
from.
We have gathered a team,
and this team is
very international.
So it's across different continents
and I challenge you to find
a funding scheme which
allows you to do this like CIFAR
really for
them it's not a problem.
On the contrary for them
it's even an asset
yeah.
And we saw that this is really a very complex
project that the 2 of us could not master
ourselves, and then the most natural thing
that came to our mind is CIFAR.
CIFAR can do this.
CIFAR connect fast, it can enable collaborations.
Also CIFAR has a track record of enabling collaborations
very efficiently.
CIFAR can do this fast, and also it can glue
these participants together and into one program
and hold an organization together.
And of course this in turn later on will also
have impact on the other disciplines as these
techniques and [INAUDIBLE] develop will later
on have impact on [INAUDIBLE] material science,
[INAUDIBLE].
And this is strongly related to questions
such as what happened during the big bang?
Why is there more matter than anti-matter?
So why are we here actually?
What is the nature of dark matter that we
observe in the universe?
And how actually these processes of these
particles, these fundamental building blocks
how this takes place.
[Music]